it may be New Year but on the Korean
Peninsula there's a return to some of
the old belligerents of the past North
Korean leader Kim jong-un told a special
meeting of the ruling Workers Party he
would continue developing his nuclear
arsenal as Pyongyang welcomed in 2020 it
marked the expiration of the deadline
Kim had set for the u.s. to come up with
concessions installed denuclearization
talks so far Kim has stopped short of
resuming tests with long-range ballistic
missiles or nuclear weapons
knowing that would risk losing what
little chance he has of getting
concessions from the US president
because Donald Trump has been probably
the most consistent supporter for Kim
jong-un for negotiations between North
Korea and the United States to actually
continue so losing his faith would be a
great risk for mr. Kim jong-un this
hardening of North Korea's position
leaves the vague commitment by the two
leaders to denuclearization now in
tatters it also marks the end for now of
South Korea's efforts to mediate between
the two powers Seoul welcomed in the New
Year back in the familiar position of
facing an increasingly belligerent
northern neighbor I think we can make a
good relationship with North Korea and I
hope we can have a good discussion with
Trump to improve things attending a New
Year's Eve party it is mar-a-lago resort
president Trump remained optimistic we
have to do what we have to do
but he did sign a contract he did sign
an agreement talking about
denuclearization and that was signed
number one sentence denuclearization Kim
jong-un also spent much of his speech
addressing the need to develop his
country's economy with an emphasis on
self-reliance it seems to be accepted
that crippling economic sanctions will
stay in place and may even be further
tightened as a punishment for any
renewed testing but the past two years
of summit diplomacy not only with the US
but also North Korea's neighbors leaves
the country far less isolated than it
was before and it's continuing weapons
development means it goes into 2020 with
more advanced missile technologies and
an expanded nuclear program Rob McBride
al Jazeera Seoul